[Music]
whether it's Halloween a cosplay event
or simply because you can looking like a
cartoon character is definitely not an
easy job
well these 10 people have totally
mastered looking like a cartoon
character we are loving the real-life
Elsa and Anna don't forget to subscribe
to our Channel and give this video a big
thumbs up today we're checking out 10
people who totally nailed dressing up
like a cartoon character
queen grimhilde from Snow White and the
Seven Dwarves The Queen from this Disney
movie is not an easy look to pull off
you'll need to have an amazing poker
face beautiful eyebrows a dark lipstick
and some impressive queen-like clothes
queen grimhilde was on a mission to
destroy Snow White's happiness and
luckily she failed but this doesn't mean
that the character was completely
unlikable considering how many people
are trying to pull off the sassy and
fierce Queen look this talented lady
pulled off the impossible and even
upgraded the look by adding some cool
details
her name is Saraswathi and she's known
as the queen of Luna on Instagram check
out her in very impressive look of queen
grimhilde she added some vyd Azal to the
original queen's look and made her look
a million times better we're in love
with the added lightning bolts on each
side of her cheeks
Saraswathi went for a slightly different
eyebrow look than the classic Queen's
arched eyebrows but we think it works
perfectly
her eyes might not be like green but
these dark eyes sure bring out the scary
look in saraswathi's version
queen grimhilde was featured in several
different shows and movies and was
portrayed by Charlize Theron Julia
Roberts Lucy Laverne and many others but
if Disney ever needed a modern
adaptation Saraswathi could definitely
play the part
Snow White from Snow White and the Seven
Dwarves and you know we can't talk about
queen grimhilde without mentioning Snow
White our cute look is definitely easier
to portray than the Queen's but you'll
still need to have impressive makeup
skills to master Snow White's complexion
and not to mention that beautiful hair
but who knew that a person would be able
to cosplay as an even cuter version of
Snow White well this could be called the
very extreme level of cosplay her name
is Sarah Engle and she's taking disney
impressions to the neck
level sarah has spent more than 14
thousand dollars on outfits that would
make her look like her favorite Disney
Princesses and it's paying off her
snow-white look might even be cuter than
the actual Snow White Sarah performs as
a Disney princess at many events
birthday parties and she also visits
children at hospitals and spends time
volunteering all while being dressed as
a Disney Princess she makes her own
dresses and she said she can take up to
six months to make one she has some
really impressive natural features that
automatically make her look like a
Disney Princess but when you add a Snow
White costume she really does pull off
the best Disney Princess we have ever
seen would you ever spend thousands of
dollars to look like your favorite
Disney character Ariel from The Little
Mermaid so let's explore some other
looks Sara could definitely pull off we
all know that Ariel's look was
originally inspired by Alyssa Milano but
Sara would be our second favorite choice
this girl really knows how to work those
Disney features and bring them to life
Sara says that her big eyes naturally
help with her cartoon like look but it's
the homemade outfit that really do the
job her goal is to actually be a real
Disney Princess one day and she says her
favorite character of all time is Ariel
well we think she already is a Disney
Princess just check out her impressive
Ariel outfit the red hair and the makeup
are made with such detail that it really
is perfect it's safe to say that Sara
might be the biggest Disney fan ever
this Ariel costume looks simple to make
right well it's actually not that simple
it can take Sara up to 3 hours to put
together her look and we bet it must
feel pretty good when she's able to
remove her makeup and take the layered
costumes off at the end of the day what
do you think of Sara as Ariel could she
pull this off or do you still prefer the
original Little Mermaid Moana the movie
Moana was only released in 2016 but it
became such a hit we've already seen
some pretty impressive Moana costumes by
2017 the 16 year old is definitely not
your average Disney Princess sure she
has an animal sidekick but Mona's
looking features are slightly more
modern than the classic Disney
Princesses we know and love this lady
didn't need to try very hard to look
like Moana she seems to already channel
the singing princess on her
but she's not the only one that's
totally owning the Moana look cosplayer
Marissa Ragsdale also looks great as our
favorite Polynesian princess as does Ali
ravallo
who actually plays Moana in the movie
you think that Mona's look was based on
Ali right well it turns out that she was
actually the last person to audition for
the role and it was only after she was
scouted for the part although we're not
sure other Moana look-alikes can sing we
know for a fact that Ali is able to belt
amazing notes she jokingly said she got
her wonderful voice from screaming and
shouting as a baby which one of these
Moana look-alikes is your favorite ours
is definitely Ali but she already looks
like a princess without the additional
need for a cosplay Marge Patty and Selma
from The Simpsons
but enough about Disney Princesses
because there are many more cartoon
characters people dress up as like these
ladies for example they're totally
rockin the look of Marge Patty and Selma
from The Simpsons we have so many
questions about this photo who are these
people and how do they manage to
recreate our favorite Simpsons women
with such simple materials can you tell
them apart Marge is in the light green
dress Selma is in blue and Patty is in
purple in the real version of The
Simpsons Patty and Selma are Marge's
chain-smoking older twin sisters who are
very rarely seperated from each other
did you know that Marge Patty and Selma
are all voiced by the same actress Julie
Kavner gave her raspy voice to all three
characters both Patty and Selma have a
strong dislike for Homer Simpson and it
seems like the feelings are mutual but
we on the other hand love this real-life
version of The Simpsons trio the human
Patty and Selma actually look like
they're also twin sisters how long do
you think it took them to paint their
skin yellow now all we're missing is
Homer and you'd get a real-life Simpsons
show Alice from Alice in Wonderland get
ready to be totally mesmerized by this
next cosplayer who truly nailed the look
of Alice in Wonderland
her name is Saraswathi and you've
already seen her from the Queen cosplay
we showed you earlier it looks like this
girl truly has the talent of dressing up
as cartoon characters Saraswathi is
actually known for incorporating her a
job into her cosplays and her
transformations are simple
stunning check out her incredible look
of Alice in Wonderland
we're completely mesmerized by her eyes
in the creative way she used a yellow
hijab and tied alice's black bow around
her head
we loved the detail of actual Wonderland
in the background and even the white
rabbit made an appearance her Alice in
Wonderland transformation really is an
original way of incorporating hijab into
her cosplay the original Alice was
inspired by a little girl named Alice
Liddell who was in fact a brunette not a
blonde and did you know that the
Cheshire cats tree actually stands in
the garden of Alice Liddell's childhood
home how cool is that
although the real-life Alice doesn't
really look like her cartoon inspired
character it's safe to say that
Saraswathi has her own look down to a
tee Mulan from Mulan saraswathi's
mission behind her cosplay talent is to
let people see a different side of the
Muslim stereotype and educate that women
with a hijab are the same as everyone
else
we saw her dress as the Queen and Alice
but her Mulan look he's also very very
impressive once again she incorporated
her job as a part of Mullins dark hair
she has even drawn a strand of hair at
the front this really is a spectacular
move on look saraswathi has perfectly
arched eyebrows her cheeks have just the
right amount of blush her eye makeup is
exactly the same and even her lips are
looking just like Milan's lips call us
impressed because we are really digging
this cosplayers artwork to look like her
favorite cartoon characters even her
clothing looks very much on point and
we're starting to wonder how long it
takes her to create such amazing looks
Saraswathi said she's a self-taught
makeup artist so we're guessing it took
quite a few attempts before she was able
to create such amazing cosplay
characters although the real-life Mulan
was based on a Chinese myth Saraswathi
has proven to us that she could
basically play the part of any Disney
Princess this marble from Avengers
Assemble if you're a fan of Marvel
Comics more specifically MS marvel stay
tuned because you'll be shocked by this
next impressive dress-up it belongs to a
popular cosplayer who goes by the name
of Katie George her dress-up is so
impressive it won her several awards and
she was even featured in cosplay
documentaries check out her absolutely
stunning impression of MS marvel doesn't
she look exactly the same
MS Marvel's real name is
Carol Danvers and if she was a real
person it might as well be Katie George
her blonde hair the dark mask and her
complete outfit this might just be one
of the most impressive cosplayers ever
MS Marvel is actually quite an
impressive character and one of the most
underrated superheroes ever even Barack
Obama is a fan of the 2014 MS marvel who
was the first Muslim American superhero
with a standalone series well we're
certainly fans this cosplayers amazing
work the next character might not be as
popular as a Disney Princess or a Marvel
character but her look can be very
difficult to pull off here are a couple
of hints she belongs in a gang she's
madly in love with one of the other gang
members she drives a mystery van and she
hangs around with a dog that can talk
have you figured it out yet Daphne from
scooby-doo its Daphne from scooby-doo
and this cosplayer totally nailed her
look Daphne usually wears a light green
scarf and a cute purple dress with pink
tights and this lady got the Daphne look
down to 18 the original real-life Daphne
was played by everyone's favorite
vampire slayer' Sarah Michelle Gellar
but this woman's look comes in a close
second
wait a minute is that Velma and Shaggy
in the background it looks like the
whole scooby gang was back together once
again but did you know that two members
of the Scooby Gang are actually married
in real life and that they have children
Sarah Michelle Gellar who played Daphne
and Freddie Prinze jr. who played Fred
have been married since 2002 although no
cosplayers will ever come close to their
original Scooby Gang look we are
completely in love with this version of
Daphne but the award for the best
cosplayers ever definitely go to our
next pair of twin sisters who managed to
look like our two favorite characters
it's hard enough to cosplay one person
but it's even harder to pull off
characters that are sisters especially
Disney's sisters can you tell who it is
one of them really wants to build a
snowman and the other one just wants to
let it all go Elsa and Anna from frozen
it's Elsa and Anna our favorite frozen
characters this awesome cosplay belongs
to Cindy and Karen twins who have
absolutely nailed their look as Elsa and
Anna don't they look absolutely perfect
their natural facial features already
enable them to look like Disney
Princesses but
astounded by just how much they look
like Elsa and Anna with their hair
makeup and clothes they might as well be
crowned as frozen look-alikes although
the original Elsa and Anna aren't twins
these Disney fans are some of the best
frozen cosplayers we have ever seen they
even managed to find someone that looks
like Kristoff and perfectly recreated
some of the scenes from our favorite
Disney movie dressing up as a cartoon
character is hard work but these people
really do make it look easy
did you know that the original Elsa and
Anna could end up with completely
different voices Kristen Bell and idina
menzel originally auditioned to play
Rapunzel in tangled although they didn't
work out it definitely opened some
unexpected doors do you think frozen
would be any different with someone else
singing the famous let it go and do you
want to build a snowman we bet these
cosplayers would definitely be able to
pull it off if you could dress up as any
character which one would it be let us
know in the comments for more videos
like this one check out 10 kids cartoon
characters reimagined as people see you
next time bye bye
[Music]